[Music]
[Applause]
the rebound nine boards for Leonard
around gets them out of their seats the
Raptors have blown this one open 27 for
Russell letter
[Music]
[Applause]
lizards
[Applause]
aid here Hawaiian let it play in his
city game hey coming
no he hasn't gotten hot track 1620 in
this game Crowder has it's a call by
thirty you know how strong the left is a
little more emotion and I saw he was fed
up at the beginning of the game maybe
taking a couple of plays he doesn't use
it like that trying to loosen up in here
Lowry to kowai kowai
1:20
25 he's gonna make something happen
well here he goes right by the guy yet
there it is whistle
blown right by the defender and the
rotating guy too late but how about the
fact that he catches he gets it he gets
the foul it gets hit hard but he plays
the glass step against Harkless played
two-man game here Miller gets switched
on to him Pillai for the win no timeout
no time now that's the ballgame
[Applause]
[Applause]
Leonard peeks at the clock five seconds
let it makes his move they got 13 and 10
with three assists in one emphatic
finish up over the top of a 16 right now
that is trying to survive on the road
they outscored the 76ers 37 to 17 and
another Kauai light that good sentence
for the sixes in this game
[Applause]
the latest one from Leonard
[Applause]
[Applause]
fifteen fourth-quarter points by Kawhi
Leonard
[Applause]
that comes middleton goes behind the
back and walk
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Leonard gets away from Paulo and throws
it to rock the way Suri kicks it out
Thompson shot block by Leonard swatted
out of bounds up into him five to shoot
Leonard's gonna try another one Serge
Ibaka
inside pass leather hey it's Taylor
rooks with bleacher report make sure
that you hit that subscribe button for
more videos